not too long ago we covered the Giants
of Norse mythology which for some can be
quite confusing because they are
essentially almost a sub race within
another race known as the owner luckily
for us Giants in Greek mythology are
exactly what their name would suggest a
group of giant humanoids who are often
destructive in nature which is something
they share with their Norse counterparts
along with several not so friendly
interactions with their traditional
deities so it would appear there may be
a slight correlation between being giant
in size and being a giant douche bag at
least in mythological stories but even
then not all Giants were bad and the
purpose of this video is to examine all
aspects the good the bad and the ugly
and believe me there are some
weird-looking Giants before we delve any
further a quick word from today's
sponsors raid shadow legends raid is
available now on both Android and iOS
and is completely free to download if
you are someone who enjoys RPGs and
you've been looking for something to
play on your phone then I highly
recommend that you give raid a try
because it has a ton of great features
the awesome 3d graphics almost make you
forget that you are indeed playing a
mobile game the story is fun and
engaging and the voice acting certainly
contributes to this the boss fights a
huge and chaotic and if you'd like to
battle against other players you can
because there is a PvP element to the
game
however if customization and visuals are
more your thing there are hundreds of
champions to collect and customize just
the way you like if you're still
undecided you don't have to take my word
for it
the game has over 200,000 reviews on the
Play Store with an almost perfect score
there's even a new awesome reward system
that allows new players to collect a
daily log in reward for the first 90
days raid has an extremely fast growing
community and you can join today for
free using my link in the description
and the ping comment below you'll also
get 50,000 silver coins and a free epic
champion for doing so so go and check
the game out because it not only
supports me but also companies willing
to reach out to creators of all sizes
anyway back to today's video we should
probably first discuss the origin of
giants and who the first Giants actually
were it's not unreasonable to say that
the first giant beings were either the
primordial deities or the Titans but
there is a difference between a giant
being that is divine in nature and a
giant being that is well just giant this
divinity often comes in the form of some
kind of power or quality that
distinguishes and sets them apart from
ourselves now that doesn't mean Giants
can't be divine or possess some kind of
special gift it's just much harder to
come by with that explanation aside the
very first Giants did of course come
from the gods the children of Uranus and
Gaia the sky and the earth but the
latter is what we should really focus on
because Uranus and his giant children
never had much of a relationship outside
of disgust and disappointment Gaia gave
birth to several different sets of
children the original 12 Titans the
Cyclopes and the Hecate increse the
Titans were about as close to human
looking deities as you could imagine but
the Cyclopes and hecatomb Crees were
certainly not and these are arguably the
first Giants that we encounter the
Cyclopes were pretty much just one-eyed
Giants and the hecatomb Crees were
giants with 50 heads and 100 hands which
is pretty much the direct translation to
their name 100 hands or 300 handed ones
so what's the big deal here the guy gave
birth to some Titans and some
weird-looking Giants but she loved them
all the same right well yes but the
issue here is with the father of the
year Uranus who found the Hecate
encrease so repulsive that when they
were born he shoved them back inside of
the womb the twice-born is often a title
given to Dionysus because he was taken
out of his mother and then later born
from Zeus's thigh but the hecatomb crews
were the first to have the pleasure of
being born twice fearing these
monstrosities Uranus locked both the
Cyclopes and hokotan quarries away in
Tartarus
when Uranus was later castrated and
Cronus assumed his father's position he
also shared his father's disdain for his
nun tight and siblings and showed little
to no interest in releasing them leaving
them exiled in Tartarus for many more
years so I guess the father of the Year
award is actually up for discussion
you have Uranus who despised his
children so much that when they were
born he forced them back inside of their
mother and then sentenced them to a life
of exile you then of course have Cronus
who were so scared that one day his
children would overthrow him that he
decided to eat them as soon as they were
born I'll leave you to decide who the
winner is in the comments below
with the Titans now the ruling
generation the Cyclopes and Hecate
encrease just festered away in Tartarus
with no real hopes of being set free
that is until Zeus made them a
proposition that they could not refuse
side of the Olympians in their war with
the Titans and he would set them free
and so they join Zeus and his fellow
Olympians in this battle known as the
Titan ìmake when they eventually emerged
victorious Zeus honored his word and
gave them their freedom the original
three Cyclopes were skilled craftsmen
and weapons myths and they made a lot of
the gods weaponry armor and trinkets
there were other Cyclopes later on down
the line but these didn't come from Gaia
and they were far less friendly than the
original three there is a more detailed
video on the channel devoted to just
these cyclops or the Cyclopes if that is
something you'd be interested in the
Hecker's hungary story is somewhat of a
Redemption arc they were always seen as
these enormous monsters who could barely
function because each one had fifty
screaming heads and 100 hands flailing
around all over the place
they were basically giants made up of
smaller organisms considering their
early lives consisted of being shunned
neglected imprisoned and despised by
most of their family it isn't a huge
surprise that they became the deform
monstrosity their father always believed
them to be regardless they got their act
together when given the opportunity
perhaps Zeus giving them control of
their own lives meant they were finally
able to gain control of their own bodies
and act in unison or maybe just the
thought of using all 100 of those hands
to throw giant boulders at their Titan
siblings who had treated them so poorly
over the years was all the motivation
they needed when the Titanomachy was
over they were given numerous rewards
for the role that they played from
underwater palaces to a pic of
Poseidon's daughters to Mary but most
importantly they will no longer treated
like monsters in the end they chose to
guard the gates of Tartarus because when
squashing your siblings with giant
boulders isn't enough why not just
become their prison guards to ensure
that they never escape you also have to
appreciate the irony of the Titans being
sentenced to a lifetime in the same
prison they once condemned their
siblings to with those same siblings
using all 100 of those hands to point
and laugh and maybe even make some other
gestures so at this point in time the
Olympians have defeated the Titans and
everything is nice and peaceful right no
of course not seeing her children
dethroned Gaea wanted to restore what
she believed to be the natural balance
but in order to do so she would have to
defeat her grandchildren who had already
proven this would be no easy task and so
in the depths of Tartarus she gave birth
to Ty Fionn an actual monster well
technically the father of monsters was
the name given to him hyphens appearance
can vary depending on the source but a
fairly common depiction is that of a
giant with the torso of a man enormous
wings and serpents for arms and legs
some say each hand and leg had 50
serpent heads and from his torso was
another hundred with only one of these
heads resembling a human from his eyes
and mouth came turrets of fire this
somewhat human appearance is white - is
considered a giant at times although
some of the earliest depictions instead
show him as merely an enormous serpent
but he definitely still warrants a
mention as one of the most influential
Giants in Greek story
he was born with only one real purpose
to dethrone and destroy the Olympians
you can argue that he was created out of
revenge and anger and that is why he
takes such a monstrous form or perhaps a
month off his magnitude and Dredd is the
only thing the Olympians would fear the
gyres plan at first seemed to be working
the Olympians sought - as he pillaged
and set fire to their cities and stood
by idly in fact most of them were so
scared that they transform themselves
into animals and fled south to Egypt
only Zeus and a few stragglers remained
when Zeus took his first stand against
the monster he was defeated with
relative ease but - refused to kill the
God instead he sliced out his tendons
and sinews leaving him unable to walk
and humiliated eventually the remaining
gods retrieve the sinews and tendons and
with Zeus at full strength he would
faced - a second time and this time he
would be victorious in some stories he
then cast - into Tartarus with the rest
of Gaius children and in others he
buried the giant under Mount Etna
whenever the volcano rumbled that was
thought to be the sound of Taif and
trying to escape the entire story of -
may have just been a way to explain the
destructive nature of volcanoes at first
glance they obviously both caused
destruction - anything in their path
volcanic eruptions are essentially
expelling heat from the Earth's core to
stop it from overheating and when that's
all done what you're left with is
volcanic soil which is extremely rich
and fertile plants may have been
destroyed but new ones grow back in
their place and new life is formed the
entire purpose of Typhoon was not to
destroy everything we know but merely to
dethrone the Olympians symbolizing a
fresh start or a new beginning somewhere
in between his mission to destroy the
Olympians he found time to take a
monster wife known as a kid nur and
together they had a bunch of monster
children hence the name the father of
all monsters now obviously this isn't a
literal title because there are other
monsters
didn't come from - but he did father
some of the most well-known monsters and
creatures some of these children
included the Hydra the Chimera the
Sphinx and even Cerberus regardless of
whether you want to class - as a giant a
Titan or a giant Titan snake he still
played a large role in the mythos and
not just because he fathered so many
monsters but because his death
symbolized the end of the Titan ìmake
and the start of the Olympian rule with
the exception of Taif and the Olympians
seemed to have a pretty good
relationship of the Giants early on so
where did this overall hatred even stem
from this is where the Giganta McKee
comes into play the war between the
Giants and the gods the biggest
mythological event involving Giants
within Greek mythology despite this
there are very few accounts of this
event from poets we often look to such
as Hesiod or Homer instead most of what
we see early comes from ancient
paintings sculptures and pottery we
don't really get any written accounts
until poets and historians such as
Xenophon EES apollo Gnaeus of rhodes and
pinterest start to provide some details
with the latter given us the first
accounts of the battle itself pindaris
believed that the prophet Tiresias
foretold of a battle where Heracles
would slay many giants where the king of
giants himself Porphyrion is killed by
an arrow from Apollo in this battle we
also see zu striking a giant with a
thunderbolt and Dionysus stabbing one
with his IV staff and Athena fending off
a giant wielding her Gorgon encrusted
shield we don't know for sure why the
battle started because none of the early
sources really explain this aspect we
only know that pin Duras believed it
took place on a peninsula somewhere in
Macedonia several reasons for this
battle began to later surface sometime
after the 2nd century AD and these
reasons ranged from the giant Alka næss
stealin Apollo's cattle to the giant
gyro Medan raping her
and even Gaia just wanting more revenge
for her children being imprisoned in
Tartarus with it being Greek mythology
all of these reasons make sense but I
personally like to think of it as Gaia
continuing her revenge after typhoon was
unsuccessful
although Hesiod never discusses the
battle itself
he describes Giants in a similar manner
to Athena in terms of them being born
ready for battle
granted Athena welding a sword and
shield when she was born doesn't paint
the same image as Giants throwing
burning oak trees and boulders when they
were born one is obviously more
destructive than the other
the idea of giants being this
destructive force the second they're
born is why I prefer guys revenge as the
explanation for this entire war we've
already seen her attempt to the throne
Olympians once before so Giants being
born this way is quite literally a
reflection of their mother's rage it
also explains some of the bad blood
between the two if Giants share their
mother's fury in Ovitz interpretation
this battle took place in the heavens as
the Giants stormed Olympus they were
then struck down by Zeus's Thunderbolts
and from their blood Gaia created a new
race of Giants who like their fathers
would also hate the gods there's also a
pretty early version of this story that
discusses a prophecy that states the
gods could not kill the Giants alone
they would need the help of a mortal and
this is where the involvement of
Heracles began before he was summoned a
guy who began searching for a rare plant
that would protect the Giants against
the gods but when Zeus got word of this
he stopped the Sun from rising and
harvested all of the plant before it
could be used against them
Heracles was then summoned and one of
the Giants he killed was Alka næss well
he actually killed him several times but
every time he did he just got back up
Alka næss couldn't die whilst in his
native land so it's likely the battle
didn't take place on Olympus in this
particular interpretation athena
suggested killing the Giants and then
dragging him outside of the borders of
his city and when Heracles did this the
giant died to his previous wounds the
war itself always seems to end in the
same way with the Giants being killed
and Gaia ending her quest for revenge
but that isn't to say she forgave her
grandchildren I guess she just accepted
that they were the rulers the constant
battle between God and giant can also be
equated to the constant fight against
nature so we did mention a few of the
Giants who were slain and I guess we can
list some off in a tad more detail
Porphyrion was a giant born from Gaia
and the blood of Uranus when he was
castrated Giants born in this way who
took part in the war of the gods were
collectively known as the giganta's the
earliest accounts regarded Porphyrion as
the greatest of giants the closest thing
they had to a king according to pin
Duras during the battle he attacked both
Hera and Heracles Zeus being a bit weird
made it so the giant fell in love of his
wife and when he tried to rape Hera he
was struck by a thunderbolt from Zeus
and an arrow from Heracles the cordons
of pindaris this arrow may have come
from apollo instead Alcon is as we
mentioned was the giant who could not be
killed whilst in the boundaries of his
city and so Heracles had to physically
drag him over the border for him to
succumb to his wound this story for the
most part doesn't have much variation
other than the fact that some people
believe Heracles killing the giant had
nothing to do that again to make-- both
events took place at different times the
giant cry tears burnt to death by her
car taste torches another giant by the
name of - was also burnt to death but
this time by Zeus and Hephaestus Palace
was the giant with impenetrable skin who
a thena killed and then flayed using his
skin as a cloak and a cover for her
shield Agrius was a giant who had the
displeasure of being beat to death by
the Mariah and their bronze clubs
ureters was the giant that we mentioned
earlier that Dionysus stabbed with his
IV starve
according to Homer the king of giants
was actually Yuri Medan and this also
happens to be the giant who raped Hera
and started the war to begin with there
are several Giants who had just
mentioned by name and it's alluded to
that many other unnamed Giants died
during this conflict I guess the
simplest way to explain the dragon
tamaki is that mother Gaia told the
Giants the Olympians were evil and they
must be stopped
the Giants then stormed a limb
so wherever this battle took place and
they were like hey mom said you guys are
being dicks oh we have to kill you now
and then they realized they bit off more
than they could chew and the Olympians
killed them all big shout-out to the row
MVPs of this battle with MRI who despite
being three elderly women still managed
to dust off their clubs and beat the
crap out of some Giants with them even
after the war there were still numerous
accounts and stories that featured
Giants and as I'm sure many of you have
guessed they normally end with a Giants
Lane of some kind
the a Lodi were the giant sons of
Poseidon or as I like to refer to them
the dumb and dumber
of Greek mythology one day they decided
to storm Olympus and to do this they
stacked three mountains on top of each
other in order to reach the top when
they eventually got there they were met
by Ares whom they managed to overpower
and imprison in a giant bronze urn for
just over a year when the gods finally
realized he was missing they sent
Artemis to retrieve him the Giants made
some demands about wanting Artemis as a
bride in exchange for Ares as the two
were keen hunters but Artemis had other
ideas she transformed herself into a
deer and darted in between the two
Giants who drew their Spears and lunched
away the only thing they managed to
impale however was each other
and they died shortly after this act of
friendly fire because when you're tired
of slaying Giants just leave them alone
and they'll probably kill each other
anyway I did promise some weird giants
at the start of the video and there are
quite a few
garyun was a giant that consisted of
three bodies joined together with four
pairs of wings not sure how that makes
any sense or what that even looks like
to be honest he lived on a secluded
Island that was surrounded by the river
Oceanus geureon was most famed for his
prized red cattle when Heracles arrived
on the island with the intention of
taking the cattle back he ended up
killing the herdsmen you ideon the
two-headed dog authoress and then
geureon himself so I guess that red
cattle was kind of symbolic of the
bloodshed Tallis of Crete was known as
the very last bronze man
in some accounts he was part of a race
of bronze giants and in others he was a
giant automaton built by Hephaestus he
would patrol the shores three times a
day hurling rocks at pirates and
invaders he would eventually be killed
when he tried to stop jason and the
argonauts landing on the island by the
witch Medea who promised to make him
immortal but instead she drove him into
madness another giant mentioned quite
often is argus Penna pitous the one
hundred-eyed giant who as his name may
suggest had 100 eyes located all over
his body
argus appears in one of Zeus's many
affairs this time with the nymph known
as io when hera caught the two together
zeus transformed io into a cow to try
and hide the affair i guess hera didn't
fall for this trick and she demanded he
gave for the cow as a gift she then
appointed Argos to guard this cow so
Zeus couldn't transform her back and
continue the affair without her knowing
now this is Zeus of course a hundred I
giant is never gonna stop him having an
affair and so he enlisted the help of
Hermes who lowered the giant to sleep
with some music and then pulled out he
sword and stabbed him to death oddly
enough this story was then used to
explain a peacock and it's feathers
because of his service heretic Argus's
eyes and placed them on the tail of a
peacock which was her sacred bird some
other Giants worth an honourable mention
are the two brothers Agrius and aureus
the Giants who were half man half bear
because of their cannibalism the gods
transform them into an owl and a vulture
arrastia was one of the few giants who
fled the Battle of the Gods and as a
result they transformed him into a dung
beetle because I guess he pooped himself
during the battle
kreisau was known as the golden giant
and the son of Medusa and Poseidon and
lastly Orion was a giant closely linked
to Artemis as either a lover or
companion to summarize the Giants of
Greek mythology at first glance are a
bunch of angry destructive antagonists
in most stories there are some albeit
very few who have a positive or even
neutral presence once we dig a bit
deeper you can see that this rage and
need for revenge stems from their mother
Gaia so how much of this can be blamed
on the Giants my guess we'll never
really know from a symbolic standpoint
if the Olympians represent change in
some form of unnatural advancement then
the Giants our nature itself the adverse
reaction to change and progress it's a
conflict that symbolizes the
ever-present battle between the comfort
of where we stand now and what is deemed
moral and acceptable in order for us to
progress regardless of how hard we try
to hold on to what seems familiar to us
per Gress and change is always the
inevitable outcome or maybe you just
look at Giants as nothing more than a
bunch of big dumb dumb cavemen who throw
rocks and trees at people and who end up
being burnt stabbed squash zapped and
transformed into something entirely
different both are fine with me as
always I've been your host mythology and
affection explained
[Music]